it was huge productive and
extraordinarily important 24 hours for
president Trump and the deranged hate
Trump left they are spinning out of
control beyond even my predictions calls
for impeachment vulgar tirades plans for
a 70% federal tax hike a bill to
radically alter the US Constitution now
it's only day two of the Democratic
controlled hate Trump House of
Representatives the wheels are coming
off it's not a pretty picture
and as you watch tonight's monologue be
sure to ask yourself this important
question we'll be asking questions they
never ask in the media is what you are
hearing and seeing and witnessing is it
good for you for your family is it good
for the country we love we start today
with our congressional watch I've long
warned you that in a hundred days the
entire country will know what we know
and that is just how radical this new
Congress is and we're getting off to a
quick start
just hours last night after getting
sworn in you have congresswoman Rasheeda
Talib went on a profanity-laced rant
while screaming for the president's
impeachment by the way they filed that
yesterday too they were in a rush for
what reason god only knows
take a look people love you and you win
and when your son looks at you says mama
look you won bullies don't win baby they
talk because we're gonna go in there win
it all right so do you need any more
proof that impeachment was their top
agenda item for the Democrats remember
they were telling Maxine Waters just
don't say it don't say it we're gonna do
it but don't say it by the way he'll
never get a conviction in the Senate
they need 2/3 of the Senate to get a
conviction it's not going to happen in
spite of all the hype all the hysteria
that you're gonna be hearing every
single day the media's lying to you now
is this what the Democratic Party has
become the media they hate Trump every
second every minute every hour of every
day and today this same congresswoman
doubled down on our dumb remarks
tweeting quote I will always speak truth
to power hashtag unapologetically me
but today to leave was little too afraid
to answer reporters questions including
Sirius XM Patriots Carrie Pinkett friend
of the show she asked her directly and
well she don't really want to give an
answer
take a look so much about speaking truth
to power now Carrie Pinkett also got
exclusive footage of two leaves
Democratic colleagues defending this
vulgar tirade and supporting the
president's impeachment I warned you
they never were ever going to tell you
what the real agenda is and the fact
that the president went out campaign
helped a lot of senators kept the Senate
in Republican hands is a huge win for
the president and he didn't lose 69
seats like Obama or 60 seats like Bill
Clinton Clinton lost eight Senate seats
Obama lost six Obama lost 63 House seats
take a look we shall see the results of
intelligence committees
molars investigation the crosswalk
national standard is high crimes and
misdemeanors which include our balloon
treason so when anybody else
and as we continue our Hannity
congressional watch the leader of the
hate Trump Democrats newly Kranz Speaker
Nancy Pelosi
also defended the well impeach the mf'er
her new colleague her freshman colleague
take a look I'm not in censorship
business I don't think that I mean I
don't like that language I wouldn't use
that language I don't it can establish
any language standards for my colleagues
but I don't think it's anything worse
than the president has put the president
has said it is it's really in words have
weigh a ton and the president has to
realize that his words weigh a ton - and
the words some of the words that he used
has a direct impact on people's lives
my colleagues comments do not have an
impact on people's lives I remember I
told you on Wednesday unlike the hate
Trump media we're gonna hold all of
these people accountable
now remember yesterday Nancy Pelosi well
she had made this pledge letter she was
pledge that when we disagree we respect
each other and we respect the truth Wow
that promise lasted an entire almost 12
hours and while impeaching 45 appears to
be at the top of the giddy Democrats
hate Trump Democrats he's never going to
be convicted in the US Senate no matter
how much the phony news media in this
country they hate Trump media says it's
going to happen it's not and don't worry
by the way Democrats are also finding
plenty of time for other stupid follies
that will never pass now far-left trump
painter congressman Stephen Cohen he's
already introduced two constitutional
amendments they will go nowhere he's
wasting your time this is false hope the
media will hype it up and it'll never
happen one that would eliminate the
electoral college one that outlaws the
president from pardoning himself not
gonna happen and just as we predicted
they also want their crumbs back but
they didn't tell you that during the
election did you that's why we now have
Hannity watch on socialism here's our
update tonight in order to fund a plan
for the so-called green New Deal
congresswoman Alexandria Acacio Cortez
she's now calling get this she wants a
70% federal tax rate for the rich 70
percent now if you live in New York you
have a ten percent state income tax
that's eighty if you work in New York
City that's another four percent if you
live in Westchester or Nassau County the
two highest property tax counties in the
country that's ninety cents of every
dollar she wants people to pay but she's
saying only 70 cents out of every dollar
or 70 percent nationally take a look you
look at our tax rates back in the 60s
and when you have a progressive tax rate
system your tax rate you know let's say
from zero to $75,000
maybe 10% or 15% etc but once you get to
like the tippy tops on your 10 millionth
dollar
sometimes you see tax rates as high as
60 or 70 percent that doesn't mean all
10 million dollars are taxed at an
extremely high rate but it means that as
you climb up this ladder you should be
contributing more that's why the hannity
watch on socialism is so important by
the way one note to the newly inducted
congresswoman of UL sworn in we now have
the bottom 50% of wage earners in
America they pay less than 3% of the
taxes we already have what you're
calling for on a pretty high level but
that's why Hannity watch on socialism we
will update you as events warrant but
that would mean no businesses no wealthy
individual would ever invest spend money
create jobs in a place where they're
taking 70 80 cents of every dollar but
that's not at all the all the biggest
problem in the same interview
Congresswoman checks and compared
herself to FDR
she thinks she's FDR and Abraham Lincoln
take a look I think that it only has
ever been radicals that have changed
this country Abraham Lincoln made the
radical decision to sign the
Emancipation Proclamation Franklin
Delano Roosevelt made the radical
decision to embark on establishing
programs like Social Security that is
radical do you call yourself a radical
yeah you know if that's what radical
means call me a radical another a
congresswoman a car Theo Cortez you're
welcome on this program I'd love to
spend an hour talking about your great
socialist ideas and by the way while she
was saying that other Democrats they're
plotting other radical socialist
economic changes and in our hannity
watch on the economy feature tonight all
president Trump's free-market lo
regulation note low tax policies they're
working in real time for real Americans
in the month of December look at this
job numbers far exceeded all
expectations as the US economy for
December added a whopping three hundred
and twelve thousand new jobs and for the
first time by the
in 20 years we now have real wage
increase of over 3% for the American
worker 2018 ended with a record number
of Americans in the workforce our
manufacturing industry posted their
biggest job gains in 20 years
Hispanic unemployment is at its lowest
point ever add to that record low
unemployment for african-americans
asian-americans women in the workplace
youth unemployment our vets are getting
jobs in love the largest numbers we've
seen in a long time and we are now the
largest producer of crude oil in the
entire world that's right more than
Russia and more than Saudi Arabia the
lifeblood of our economy have you
noticed the price of gasoline has
dropped considerably president Trump is
making history every day the media that
hates him will never talk about it
because he's keeping his promises our
economy right now is running on all
cylinders and you probably would know it
if you watch fake news CNN or conspiracy
TV MSNBC in fact most members of the
mainstream media they have the exact
same MO as their friends in the
Democratic Party all of these disparate
groups it's all about hating Trump every
second every hour every day nothing
changes nothing else seems to matter for
example look at this CNN fake news
commentator what she had to say the
president was well he's a whiner he
whines like a baby he's a liar and he's
a whiner and I think what needs to
happen is the Republicans got to go over
there and change the president's diapers
Don that's what this is coming down to
so that he can cut it out so that the
grown folks the big girls and the big
boys can go around the table sit around
the table and do what is necessary for
this government just imagine for a
second a conservative it said that
during the Obama years now in the very
same show another pundit even attacked
Trump supporters now first we were of
course they were clinging to our God
guns and religion then we were
irredeemable deplorable then we were
smelly Walmart people and now we're all
toothless because we like Donald Trump
those of us devoted for him watch this
the wall is always been a car
for Donald Trump's credulous rube ten
tooth the wall has always been a scam it
has always been a lie nothing about the
wall has ever been real and Donald Trump
knows it actually we've been building
the wall but while uh truth and facts
get in the way of a good narrative to
hate Trump and not to be outdone a guest
on liberal Morning Joe once again
playing the race card they've been doing
this for two years take a look look this
is all Donald has left he is one thing
this wall is not a wall it is a let's
keep America white again and basically
it doesn't have the economy anymore this
is all he has less is it that one
metaphor that one thing that torques
that 39 40 41 percent base that says
either the black man or the brown man or
the Jewish man or the media man or the
banker man is coming to take your life
or your it's not your you're not in the
position you're in because of you it's
cause everybody else what I tell you
Wednesday we're in the worst
informational crisis this country has
ever faced in terms of their fixation on
hating the president we are in the
middle of a historically strong economy
strong new trade deals energy
independence a more peaceful and
prosperous world but the left is
obsessed with one thing and that's what
they're gonna feed you every hour of
every day that's why this show is
different we like to look at ourselves
as a little bit of an island or oasis
and that brings us to Hannity watch on
border security tonight and an update on
the partial government shutdown at this
hour a deal to fund the government is
facing gridlock in Washington all
because Democrats are fighting tooth and
nail against the president's vow to
secure our borders with strategic walls
and fencing a wall that border patrol
agents as they did yesterday are asking
for a wall that protects our homeland a
wall that keeps out gang members and
potential terrorists we have a big door
for people that want to be a part of our
family and today the president
effectively advocated for this very
important issue let's take a look that's
a very dangerous trick and they bring
children or even worse they use children
you know children are the biggest
beneficiaries of what we want to do
children are hurt more than anybody else
these coyotes what they do with children
all because we have open borders because
I think they can get away with it one of
the things that happens there is human
traffickers maybe that's the worst of
all where you'll have traffickers having
three and four women with tape on their
mouths and tied up so the only way
you're going to stop that is by having a
solid steel structure or concrete
structure now the president also issued
this stern warning telling reporters
that he is willing to declare a national
emergency in order to get that wall
built let's take a look at that have you
considered using emergency powers to
grant yourself authorities to build this
wall without congressional approval and
second guess I have to go you have yes I
have and I can do it if I want so you
don't need congressional approval to
build no we can use them absolutely we
can call a national emergency because of
the security of our country absolutely
no we can do it I haven't done it I may
do it I may do it but we could call a
national emergency and build it very
quickly and it's another way of doing it
but if we can do it through a negotiated
process we're giving that a shot now my
message to the Republican Party tonight
is this is important
lives are at stake we don't want drugs
flooding into our country human
trafficking has got to stop we can't
have a potential where terrorists can
walk across our borders or gang members
that want to commit violence or the drug
cartels having access to our country
we've got to protect our borders it is
about national security even if the 99%
of people that want to come in just want
a better life you're Republicans got to
stay the course you can't back down now
the president's base is now deeply
invested in this shutdown the president
has taken a stand and it's time for the
Republicans to do the same how many more
innocent Americans think about this
would need to die before Democrats that
five years ago supported building a wall
we'll protect the border and I'm not
just talking about murder the opioid
crisis in small towns and big cities
most of those drugs especially the
heroin with fentanyl are coming into
this country from the cartels they are
targeting our kids the United States
literally is arrested thousands of
people with ties to terror organization
gang members violent cartels trying to
cross our borders along with people that
just want a better life we can have it
we can have legal immigration watch this
CBP has stopped over 3,000 what we call
special interest aliens trying to come
into the country on the southern border
those are aliens who the Intel community
has identified are of concern they
either have travel patterns that are
identified as terrorists travel patterns
or they have known or suspected ties to
terrorism so we have 3,000 that we know
about I think what the president
continues to make clear is it's our
sovereign do you need to know who comes
into our country without any kind of a
structure and without changing the laws
we have no way to know the identity of
every person that walks across the
unsecured border secretary Neal says
right it should scare every American it
needs to be taken seriously and let's
not forget border security it's also
about saving American jobs at fair wages
now the man who wrote the art of the
deal the president of the United States
is standing by button ready to negotiate
all through the Christmas holiday in the
New Year's holiday he wants the solution
as it relates to the daca he's put that
on the table something the Democrats say
they want he's willing to talk about the
dreamers as well watch this Senator
Schumer came out and said that the
meeting from his point of view and
speaker Pelosi's was contentious he also
said you said in the meeting this is him
quoting you I just want to check that
the shutdown could go on for months or
even a year or longer did you say that
and yet sure I did is that yes we are
absolutely I said that I don't think it
will but I am prepared and I think I can
speak for Republicans in the House and
Republicans in the Senate they feel very
strongly about having a safe country
having a
that makes sense without borders I've
said it many times we don't have a
country I hope it doesn't go on even
beyond a few more days it really could
open very quickly we played the tape
Democrats supported this five years ago
Hillary supported it Schumer supported
it Barack Obama supported it apparently
Nancy Pelosi doesn't care not caring
about safety and security the American
people apparently not caring about daca
recipients that they talked so much
about apparently not caring about Border
Patrol agents they were pelted with
rocks and bottles and she doesn't seem
to care about immigrants he just cares
about scoring cheap political points
which is why arrogantly she offered
president Trump $1 for the wall I guess
she was feeling giddy yesterday
take a look situation which you would
accept even a dollar of wall funding for
this president as you can see from
tonight's Hannity watch the radical base
of the Democratic Party they are already
unhinged I thought it would take like a
hundred days for to fully understand it
we're understanding it now on day two
many on the Left including nearly
everyone on every other network because
of course it's the hate Trump media they
seem to want a weaker country filled
with lofty surreal progressive
principles and they're not looking out
for the safety of you and your family
but progressive principles come with
serious consequences not only will have
unsecure borders higher taxes that leads
to economic growth that is stagnant open
borders that can lead to death and
terrorism and drugs
if progressives take over the United
States of America will drastically be in
decline is that the America you want
those are the questions we have to ask
so my humble advice is the shutdown as
much as an inconvenience some people
that work for the government and I hope
they get their back pay it needs to
continue straight through the State of
the Union and maybe beyond at the State
of the Union the president he can take
his case directly to you we the people
and while the president should support
back pay for those furloughed employees
make no mistake no matter what the
President does he must hold firm on this
border wall funding from Congress there
must be no amnesty under any
circumstances Lindsey Graham he is made
a proposed compromise that would give
daca recipients three years of a work
permit that they might be able to renew
down the line if there's no amnesty and
money for the border wall to protect the
American people then they will have
accomplished something very important
and by the way they'll politically
benefit for it but that shouldn't be the
reason they do it if they capitulate the
Republicans the political damage frankly
is incalculable and it will hound that a
lot of these people you know throughout
the rest of the Trump presidency also
will have an impact on the 2020 race the
point now is stay the course don't back
down this is important for the country